με τονα εχωρεύούν συρτάκει να ανάψουν πυρυθούς να επιάσου πάνω στην ομοπλάτη τους και ναπανεγυρίζουν
όλι κράτελλες και είναι ένας δικός τους πουτοκέρδησε για αυτό είμα λεει πάραπολλά και της
σχέση που χμαζί με την κροαδία και μετα άτομα στονομήλων εξίθου και οι γυναίκα μουκροάτηα
χουν πάροσμουχροάτης και ο δεύτερος μου πατέρας ο προμητίσμου για αυτός κρνατης είπε ρι κάποια
παράπομα που υπάρχουν σε δα φρά την όμοσπονδία ωστόσο υπάρχει ώραμα υπάρχει για τη χώρα
μας για την ιστιοπλοία θεωρίσ ότι υπάρχει μέλλο σε αυτό μελλών υπάρχει πάρα πολύ και
πάντα θα υπάρχει γιατί έχουμεαυτό πακαι πριν εο καίτο εκείπετων πυ είναι τοθααμας το τώώραμααν
υπάρχει όχι μπορεί να πον ότι υπάρχει αν είναι στον βαθμόν που θα μπορούσε εμπιστεύω
πως όχι γιατί θα μπορούσε ι θα άις με να τα γεμάτες γιατί θα μπορούσε
ν αυτό που ππριν να έχουμε να αυτική παιδιά αν παστοράσι θαλασα μόνο και μο
να να δει στους σκολιμβιτές ι πλήσταρα αυτούς θα ανεξένει εκτός από τους προϊνούς τους
χημερινούς που έχει αρκε τους κύπριους αν πάσει ώρα αντεκαδό δεκατο προίδύο το μεσημεριντρεις το
απόγευμα οι μεσχεόσίγορότίτες παραλίες η πλιοψηφία από αυτούς θα είναι ξένει δεν θα νεκύπρι περισσότερι
το έχου στο μιαλόντος οδιόταξε για να τοσχολείώ τεγειών ι το καλοκαίρι ενώ τώρα είαι
καλύτρες μας σάραες υπραγματικόδιτά και οιμέσίγορος ότι με κάτι πιο συστημικών κάτι πιο οργανωμένων με
έναν όραμαμακροπρόδεσμο θα μπορώσουμε να δώσουμε πολλά ωφέλει στην κοινωνία να φέρουμε πάρα πολλά παιδιά
κοντά και τι ιοκογίνας και τους γονείς και να αποφελήθούμε στην ουσίάν όλα αυτά που
πρί μας προσφέρει θαλας τοπράδον ελίγο στα πιο προσωπικά πώς γνωρίσε ο πάύλος τη συζιγό
του